6 41 here on monday morning we interrupt
this conversation about megan and
harry's interview
[Laughter]
we're still talking i know the whole the
whole break we're talking about
monica good morning how you doing today
i am doing good and i think it's a great
time to talk about getting away because
that interview whoo
today on mondays with monica thank you
so much john we are talking about spring
break travel during covent
and how to stay safe but you can still
have fun doing it allegionaires
executive vice president
and chief marketing officer did i do the
british accent
scott d'angelo i don't know that
interview got on my nerves but i'm so
glad we're talking to you today
good morning to you how you doing i'm
doing great and hey it sounds good to
hear it that way so keep going with that
accent well thank you
hey so scott you know everybody's
talking about spring break and that is
very cool but
we have to keep in mind we're still
dealing with the pandemic
so when you travel you got to travel
safely i've always liked your your
airline
because one it's affordable everybody
knows who you are and
but you're more than just the airline
and that's the part that i really love
talk about some of your offerings when
it comes to the las vegas community in
particular
yeah you bet so let's start with the
first one a lot of people still don't
know that
we are based here uh we're headquartered
here in las vegas we have more than 1500
employees that call
southern nevada home uh and each year
they help bring three billion dollars to
our nevada state economy so
there's that but just like you said
we're more than just an airline
we're best known for low fares on
non-stop flights
uh but we also make it easy to get great
deals on rental cars hotels
and soon to be even vacation rentals and
that's not just if you're traveling away
even for locals here you can get great
deals on staycations at
our beautiful properties here in town at
the end of the day our goal is for
allegiant.com to be your one-stop shop
for leisure travel whether it's in the
air or on the ground
and you know what i'm so glad you said
uh car rentals and the other things that
you named because my next question was
going to be
you know we all hear about low-cost
airlines okay let's just be honest about
that but
i was going to ask you what sets you
apart but you guys are doing a lot of
extra stuff now
absolutely what also sets us apart is
why we started a legion in the first
place
and that was to provide access to travel
for those
that might not be able to either because
the price was too high or because of
where they live
so we're different in a lot of ways
number one in many markets we're the
only airline
that serves them and can bring them to
world-class destinations like las vegas
all of our flights are non-stop so
you're never connecting to a congested
hub
our base airfares like you said are low
and you pay for just those things that
you want or need
but maybe most importantly from kind of
a marketing point of view is
we don't sell through the quote-unquote
middlemen you have to come directly to
allegion.com
yeah at the end of the day we are 100
leisure travel
and we embrace that role we know the
most important and exciting part of your
leisure travel experience
is the people and the places once you
get there so as a result
we're focused on getting in there as
safely
as fastly and as cheaply as we can and
you know there are a lot of other things
i want to talk to you about
scott but i know that the thing that's
top of mind for a lot of people is the
pandemic
how the heck are you going to keep us
safe in the air love your commercials
keeping us safe in the air and on the
ground
how are you going to do that when you
have so many people still not wearing
the mask just not following the rules
yeah so uh the good news is uh the the
airline industry overall but
specifically here at allegiant when we
pointed going the distance for health
and safety
we were the first to provide each and
every passenger
with the health and safety kit long
before mass were even mandatory
uh there are a ton of protocols uh
throughout the travel experience when
you're checking in
uh certainly the things we're doing to
prep the plane and all
during the flight and just really kudos
to the women and men of allegiance
yeah that are maintaining and flying our
planes uh and of course those that are
tending to passengers
uh whether it's at the stations or in
flight
all of that information is available at
legion.com
i'll tell you one other thing though in
addition to the health and safety
precautions
we're hearing from customers who we've
all been educated a lot in this last
year
and they feel responsible enough to
travel but they're asking what's open
what can i do
so we're working really closely with
great destinations
like here in las vegas to make sure that
our customers know
what's all available because a lot of
them are ready to go absolutely and hey
uh kudos to you for the name on the
stadium you know where the raiders play
[Laughter]
we love it absolutely well
let's start the raiders were a big part
of that you know i can't stress enough
to
the folks i talked to how committed the
raiders organization
is to the las vegas community in
southern nevada i mean
mark davis is a fan of all teams he now
owns not just
one but two professional sports teams
and it was important
uh as as they put a name on the stadium
that it was a local las
vegas company uh that supported jobs
here that supported economic growth here
uh so they're a big part of it uh we of
course
uh were very interested in it because
like i said you have to come to
allegion.com
and what better way to get your name out
there than
a historic venue part of the world's
most iconic just like
i mean yeah yeah let's not overthink
this one it was a great opportunity for
us
yeah scott i gotta go but thank you so
much this was a thrill chatting with you
and hey maybe we'll be booking really
soon absolutely we look forward to
seeing you on board monica take good
care
all right you too and don't forget folks
hey catch my moj show facebook live
tonight at 7 p.m